few weeks ago karsland open at Disney
California Adventure down in LA and that
got me thinking I'm a little bit of a
Disney nerd I like looking at like
Google Earth images of the parks and
trying to figure out how stuff works
there but karsland seemed to me to be
quantitatively different than the other
sorts of environmental simulations that
you'd see the Disney part because unlike
the ones that are based on just outright
fantasy or based on two-dimensional
animation cars Lions based on cars pixar
movie which means there are actual
three-dimensional objects in virtual
space that the simulation is supposed to
represent and that got me thinking about
the amount of information contained in
that simulation and whether there was
more information visual information in
the movie or in the simulation of the
movie well that turns out to be harder
to figure out that I thought it would be
the pics are folks will tell you that a
frame can take up to thirty nine hours
to render which is just a huge amount of
information right that was in a wired
story from a few years ago and it turns
out that the Imagineers disneyparks did
use some of those 3d images to build the
simulation not for the rock formations
and mountains those they had to for
shorten and change the painting on
because in the movie they're giant and
miles away and in the attraction they're
supposed to look giant miles away but
they're actually just a couple hundred
feet away and they're the walls of the
attraction but they didn't use those 3d
images for the stuff in the town
buildings and cars the characters turns
out they had to take information out to
make that work though the pics are
models were too detailed but they didn't
need the undercarriage of the cars for
example because what the Imagineers were
trying to do was use them to make a 3d
simulation a sort of virtual reality
that the designers could walk through
and plan the attraction before they
built it took them two years but the
thing together so less information but
then when they actually took those
models and went to build the physical
representations that you'd see in the
park they had to add information back in
but not the kind of permission you would
expect it wasn't visual information on
the characters themselves it was stuff
like there had to be lights to bounce
off these beautiful buildings we're in
the Pixar movies the lighting looks
beautiful but it's sort of virtual
lighting they had to change the shapes
of them so they could accommodate people
instead of cars
that meant adding in sort of the texture
of everyday life things that we see all
the time but don't think of but that
still add information to a scene now can
you quantify any of this well that's
pretty hard to you could agree with the
theory that says that the printed word
has a level of complexity information
complexity like a visual object and if
you believe that like Claude Shannon the
father of information theory and an
excellent juggler actually did then you
can figure out a level of entropy for a
printed word in bits he put the number
of 11.8 three some researchers since
then I've said it's lower or you could
try to figure out something based on how
words and letters curve and are can
dangle there's a researcher named mark
Chang easy he put a number at between
two and ten who's trying to figure out
the number of neurons in the brain that
you would need to see something complex
you had to believe the theory that says
that the human brain is evolved to be
just as complex as it needs to be to see
the most complex things in our visual
ecology and that sort of brings us back
to the difference between cars and cars
land because when we're seeing the movie
we see only what the director and what
the animators want us to see we see the
exact level of complexity they need to
tell a story they control the pan they
control the zoom but when you're in a
simulation of this fake place you're
still seeing more real stuff because you
control where your camera goes and
because you can do something as easy as
turn around right the universe exists
behind you at the same time as it exists
in front of you which it doesn't
necessarily in the movie that's why it's
a little bit trickier to try to simulate
something that's 3d rather than
something that's too deep because the 3d
gives you the illusion of more reality
but the fact is there's always more
reality out here in the real world